but when you walked away from the event
where the gentleman was sleeping on the
cardboard what happened to you in the
following weeks shortly after that
particular red carpet I got a call from
a producer who said we really really
want to use her in this movie it was the
sequel but you've got to become more
famous than you are can you get more
famous
we actually had that conversation and
then you you could hungry you get hungry
for more success more red carpets more
lists that you can be on to be famous
enough to be in that guy's movie as
opposed to the 55 other movies that
you've already got booked coming up you
want to be in the one that you don't
have how can I get more famous and then
I saw the video online of me looking
extremely uncomfortable doing this red
carpet dance well I know that there was
somebody sleeping on a piece of
cardboard 20 feet away and I just about
quit it just about made me quit because
I thought I can't do this anymore
I'm not a good celebrity what I wanted
to do with all of my tricks and all of
my magic online was to become a steady
working actor in LA and I did that I
became a very successful for me
working-class actor in Los Angeles but
what I did not count on was that there
is an additional element over which you
have no control and that is how famous
you are you can't control it but
everybody wants you to be more famous so
you can bring more money to their
project and if you get caught up in that
in thinking I need to be more than I am
you just become an ungrateful and
you start not to like yourself and it's
such a cliche it's such an actor's
cliche but people who come to this city
to work need to know that if they
achieve success they're gonna have to
decide how big a celebrity do I want to
be do I want to say the level I've
achieved is not enough I've got to be
big enough to be in that guys movie and
be on that series and are they able to
do it and for me no I I don't think I
want to be any bigger because I don't
want to be any more disassociated from
the world then I already feel so what
that little tiny bit of celebrity that
I've had that little bit of experience
what it did for me
was it made me say if you want to
preserve any craft that you have if you
want to preserve any shred of the reason
that you became an actor in the first
place you've got to step away and so I
started doing theater more and I started
touring with a Ray Bradbury piece that
means something to my heart and I
started worried and not so much about
being important and I've gone back east
much more to be with my family and my
little beach house there and it's been
very good for my soul
and the more I think about it the more I
think that I don't really want to be a
movie star because I don't have what it
takes to stand on that red carpet and
not go to the guy who's sleeping on the
piece of cardboard and say you know what
man you should be on this red carpet
somebody takes some of this food that
costs so many thousands of dollars and
feed these people that are right here at
our feet but you see that's not a part
of celebrity that's not what we do in
this business that's not what we're
about we're about ourselves and my god
I'm self-absorbed enough as it is like I
can't do that anymore
so yeah so I'll never be a movie star
but I hope I can you know be a better
person then that person was
you